monsieur bonsoir noël en montgolfière
pourquoi pas l'idée est venue à un
groupe de jeunes rockers qui ont tenté
ce matin une expérience un peu farfelues
comme le père noël ils sont remontés au
ciel mais en ballon et en musique
regardez départ en fanfare pour le
chanteur et le batteur du groupe de rock
nantais elmer food beat qui ont décidé
d'emprunter une montgolfière pour offrir
aux nantais par la voie des airs
un chant de noël de leur composition une
manière pour le jeune groupe rock de se
faire connaître et aussi de faire
plaisir aux nantais ah bah oui bien sûr
parce que là on va passer au dessus
d'eux et puis comme on aime beaucoup
nantes c'est pour ça qu'on reste un an
tacler ses produits facile de jouer à
longue pour un groupe de rock
c'est parce qu'on ait 90 et donc on va
leur offrir notre chanson de noël voilà
c'est un cadeau voilà on leur fait notre
cadeau tout simplement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
eh ben
un champ que peu de nanterre ont pu
entendre les 20 ayant poussé le ballon
vers la campagne
mais n'est-ce pas d'abord l'intention
qui courent dernières nouvelles il était
perdu loin dans la campagne
[Musique]